a mother in
anguish of the seven Palestinian men
killed early Sunday by an Israeli drone
strike four of them were
brothers in an
instant's Sons were
gone when we speak just hours later
grief is etched all over her
face
everybody knows Israel is about
terrorism they want to kill all
Palestinian people they don't want to
spare anyone they want to annihilate the
Palestinian people whether they are
young civilians or
Fighters even before she lost her
children Iam's anas was
growing I was worried every time they'd
go to Janine that they might get killed
every time but I never expected to lose
them all at once the air strike that
killed her boys was carried out in the
aftermath of an Israeli Army raid into
Janine during that raid a female Israeli
soldier was killed when an improvised
explosive device went off Palestinian
armed group Janine brigades claimed
responsibility people we spoke with say
when Israeli army vehicles left the city
at around 5: in the morning several
Palestinian men including the four
brothers were standing in this
roundabout they told us all the men were
civilians but that some of them threw
rocks and pipe bombs towards the
outgoing soldiers raids of this nature
in Janine are not uncommon they were
already a near daily occurrence even
before October 7th what's far less
common is the number of casualties and
the impact it's had on one extended
[Applause]
family Abdul nasar hanisha owns a coffee
shop across from the attack site his son
often Works alongside
him says today everything
changed I'm still trembling I'm scared
I'm scared for my children that anything
can happen to
them a sense of dread many here feel
will only
deepen Muhammad Jam jaaz
Janine make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz